um okay
let's play someone else okay let's try
one c4 this time
you see for exactly a surprise what's uh
what's wrong
f5 wow and this is how we play chance
okay nice stream
and d5 d5 is something
something that does not look brilliant
to me
yeah how should i play this i'm sort of
uh
sort of really surprised to be honest so
can i just go e4
and then knight g5
a4 he has safe takes c4 zone like
e4 was a bit smarter one more
f takes e4 knight g5 e5 does not look
good to be honest
i can also play it simple like g3 and so
on but this is a bit
this looks a bit soft for um
for the position we have
after g3 i'm slightly worried about e5
e4 e3494 does doesn't look right at all
okay i can simply play e3 obviously as
well
but these three once again it's not
exactly
the move you you want to play when you
think you're much better
maybe i'm not much better than it
explains a lot
okay let's try to be brave let's go g3
and after e5 simply
simply take on e5
like i am always
i mean always a believer in this
e5 pawn sacrifices but yeah on the other
hand he
he does not does not need to spawn on f5
at all
it's only hope for white so maybe yeah
e5 gtx5 is just better for white
so he wants to play e5 here probably but
then having
bc we are not exactly forced to
take on e5 still an option but
i mean we are definitely not forced to
do it
yeah he goes e5
we can also play it very simple like
knight xt5
take everything go f4
but then i have a feeling it could be
kind of okay for black
in general i probably played like an
idiot now
like if i allow e4 then even this f5
move
starts to make sense
um we have an increment though so
i can i can simply sing here
on the old plays on people are way more
tricky than
the new one it's a new one you win all
the games easily and here
i was crushed once and uh things keep
happening here
probably time to make a move but um
yeah i mean i don't like most of them
okay let's try queen b3 maybe
and yeah then i'll try to speed up a
little
like after e4 we go on ig5
then he has some queen f6 and then we
probably go h4 and play the game i mean
not a big fan of our position to be
honest
but at least it's sharp enough
yeah h4
then i'll try to try to reshuffle a
little like a dream scenario is to get
knight h3
and then somehow trade the bishops go
knight f4 and d3
then white would definitely be better
another question is uh h6 like we are
not forced to take
uh to go away but after knight h3 he has
some knight takes d4 maybe
but then we probably take and simply
play rugby one
and uh
yeah and it simply works
okay finally something uh something good
to find out in this game
yeah so knight h3 like i am not going to
to fight for a temporary one so he
allows queen takes b7
what is this exactly okay whatever let's
uh
let's try it like if it works he will
win some brilliant game
which has never been something we try to
avoid
yeah maybe just king d7 and you play i
mean it's a bit strange to start
thinking now
i expected him to have a plan
and i mean it does not feel like white
is winning at least to me
just looks sharp
yeah king d7 bishop g5
queen somewhere then we go e3
try to get bishop b5
yeah h6 okay i guess now bcb5 works
yeah he takes but then it should be very
very bad then we just have knight takes
g5 and then
so this is basically winning for white
okay so i don't know bishop c4 maybe
queen d7 okay we are happy with the
trade when we are two pawns up
yeah okay now we'll we'll probably win
it slowly but surely
i don't know why i decided to to play h5
but it should not be should not be too
bad as well
okay five so he's trying to desperately
to
come up with this razor but i don't see
it like a4 we take with the check even
and then we go back automatically
yeah now rookie 6 followed by rook f6
and yeah we probably went to too many
pounds here
okay now once again check on rook f6
now we grab another one
okay so we keep keeping system connect
rate
never really want to develop some
rook h2o or something even with uh
we stand spawns up
yeah but this is uh like simply
completely lost
let's have a let's have fun actually
let's give up a bishop and uh
show that this is still completely lost
for black
yeah so now we'll simply try to bring
those upon there
okay e4 h5
um e5 i believe followed by g5
okay
okay now maybe king of five
d6 and it's quite easy to play here i
must say e6
okay let's not forget about the h-phone
okay king g6 then we go with f5 f6
okay now we start promoting them
h7
thanks okay now we can promote another
one
okay here's zions fine
uh